hey numberphile my name is Lucas and I'm
a speed cuba so I'm going to solve this
Rubik's Cube for you
I'm Adam and then you can solve the
Rubik's Cube about nine point six
seconds oh okay a little bit more and
then gonna time it with this program hi
this little we keep slumming it in total
five people's hi my name is Ethan
Finland and I'm a big fan of brady
herons videos I love numberphile is
great sir
so number five and sixty symbols
periodic video number pile behind five
oh this is me really feels that I have a
really cool science channels ask for
videos of people with hands of him
solving Rubik's cubes today Rubik's
cubes
why because numberphile asked for and he
was looking for someone to solve a
mystery
hi my name is Dan and this is my
contribution to rock on numberphile
video which is about it suits I guess
okay actually got a pretty easy case hey
this beautiful great hello youtube hello
Brady this is my Rubik's Cube attempt to
solve
hey numberphile I'm Owen I'm 10 years
old and I'm going
this complete mess
hey baby you are one itself so here's
mine
here we have a Rubik's Cube well gang
I'm ready
Padma so my friend quick video and for
numberphile hello Brady this is not my
school for any hair and I hope I'm not
too late but I want to submit a video of
me solving lives of a number vile you
wanted a Rubik's Cube song so here you
go really a 10-fold bit lower lower but
in this case I'm just going to try to
have it on camera the entire time one of
the YouTube channels are follow a number
file the guy behind that Brady was
asking for videos that people solving
Rubik's cubes and I mean I'm sure I've
mentioned it before but I can't solve
one and very slowly okay and this took
24 seconds point 76 and as you can see
the cube is solved Oh be my record mom
maybe 46
there you go
alcohol
so
hi guys this is going to be a video of
me solving the Rubik's Cube for the
numberphile Channel minutes
we did it we have a place back to be two
minutes 40 seconds in there
hello it's 10 and this is me solving the
Rubik's Cube for periodic videos and
number five one time I saw you Brady my
name is Albert and I love any point for
someone I knew I said so Brady I hope
that helped and renowned for watching
and there we go Freddie lose yourself
groups
keep all the best and I hope you'll be
educating and entertaining us for the
coming decade have a good one and I hope
this helps not guess the only challenge
left is this